resort and casino showed off its hotel
tower and rooftop lounge called the
legacy club today
marking the completion of the downtown
las vegas casino resort
eight news now reporter salah sally
jaramillo was there she joins us now
live
with what we can all expect come
december 28th how exciting sally
that's right kirsten many surprises is
what you can expect and circa has a very
unique and special style
now people who come here will be able to
recognize all the many
different areas not to mention all the
gold here and the great vibes
if you have been or passed by downtown
las vegas you can't miss circa it's the
tallest tower
north of the strip on monday circa will
officially open its 458 feet tall tower
which includes 512 rooms and suites the
rooftop lounge and legacy club will also
debut
the rooms display vegas pass many
vintage design elements
each of the rooms equipped with certain
prestige king mattresses
many refrigerators dual vanities and
walk-in showers four of the suites i
toured today
corner king located on the 26th floor
circa and suite on the 21st floor
circa studio on the 31st floor and the
founders suite
on the 52nd floor i thought it was
really important
that we honor a lot of the artists that
we have
in las vegas so all of our i mean i'd
say 90 percent of the artwork we have
around
like the entire property the rooms the
casino
were done by local artists
situated atop legacy club has great
views of las vegas it's an upscale
lounge with an expansive outdoor terrace
and fire pits now their goal is to honor
the downtown area
make it new make it better and really
just have everybody come out here and
enjoy from
everything downtown las vegas has to
offer reporting live from downtown
sally jaramillo 8 news now thank you
sally i